what up people we're hitting you with a
little supplemental activity today on
the handlers will say podcast is going
to be the first in a series of lifting
vlogs i don't know how frequently
they're going to come but when we have
an opportunity to meet someone like nash
from rep works who's really good at what
he does and i've shouted his page out
before he came out to la for the day put
us through a deadlift workout now i'm
gonna leave it to nash to explain some
of the specifics
so essentially what we're gonna do we're
just gonna we're gonna work up to
something heavy for the day whatever
that means for these guys whether it's a
single or a double
then we're gonna drop back and hit some
good volume more than likely on a clock
should be in and out on the deadlift
platform in about a half hour and then
we're just gonna do some accessories
that's what it's all about he's great at
coming up with really efficient workouts
that are going to leave you
totally wiped so you're going to hit you
know deadlifts as you said half an hour
on the platform hit some accessories get
out all under an hour and you'll be
good for the day follow along
yeah exactly ref works baby
[Music]
[Music]
you went really wide like this yeah
which just means that you're not
applying force directly down
right so if you if you see me pull you
know from the deficit dude i'm right
here because then that allows me that
allows power directly down
set your legs up like this
your knees are the only point
so the first thing that's gonna do
like we said before we're just working
up to something heavy for the day
whatever that means for the guys um in
terms of like a daily heavier daily
single you just got to play it day to
day some days you're going to feel like
you can pr other days you're 80 is going
to feel like a one rep max so it's
important that you auto regulate and uh
anything that you sort of lose out on in
terms of the heavy you can make up for
with accessories pretty easy you're
using a plate to stand on to create a
deficit with your double threat what's
the logic and doing that so what i've
found that works for me as well as what
works for a lot of taller guys out there
is working with the deficit it forces
you to drive your butt down before you
pull it off the ground engaging your
quads a lot more so it keeps your lower
body to help your button that shoot up
well it doesn't help it not shoot up it
just helps you engage more parts of your
body so at that point your quads are
moving the bar a little bit more than
just your posterior yeah and so i did
that there was a lot of deficit that
looks in the program that i did that got
my deadlift up a lot you know probably
added like 100 pounds on my deadlift
what it does is it takes away the
fatigue from your lower back still gives
you this really great exhausting workout
but it distributes that fatigue
from your lower back to your quads it's
a little more even and it's not just all
like hammering your lower back so again
as he said if you're taller check it out
it might work for you
haters will say that mark can't deadlift
500 pounds yeah that's what they're
saying what are they saying they said
that you can't lit uh deadlift 500
pounds
yeah hold this [ __ ] hell haters once
you get up to a certain amount generally
like anything over 50
that you're and you're looking to find a
heavy single for the day on your warm-up
sets don't go to like failure or even
fatigue just hit it for one or two go
for speed and move on
[Music]
his back's at like a 95 right now
it's going down like i'm down
everyone needs to respond
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
there you go there you go
[Applause]
[ __ ]
oh [ __ ] back uh over the summer we were
we that was because of mass program they
had some back oh your back is still
[ __ ] recently but you know it's
pretty cool like obviously i carried
some strength over from that because i
haven't like
been doing legs that haven't been doing
lifting so yeah i'm glad that i'm still
at 500 yeah that's good
oh yeah
go go
yeah
we're pulling weight over here that's a
big boy so funny boy haters were saying
nash wouldn't even come to l.a let alone
deficit deadlift 55. haters will say
that japan doesn't stretch either wow
look at him in all his glory he's like
that feels so good it feels amazing he
was scared
you don't stretch but you we recovered
go go go yeah drive
it oh yeah
don't push it
[ __ ] push
okay so we established our heavy singles
nash and brandon hit 550 i hit 500 once
chappelle hit 455. um and so we're going
to back off and use a percentage of
those maxes to hit our volume i'll let
nash take it away yeah so today we're
just gonna we're not gonna do anything
on the clock because we got four guys
running through the bar that would make
it a little bit a little bit of a time
pinch we're gonna drop it to about 65 70
of what we hit for our heavy single
we're gonna go three sets of eight to
twelve we're not doing it on a clock per
se but we don't wanna like spend too
much time doing it so we've got four
guys going we're gonna hit one after
another after another
[Music]
so we just uh established a heavy single
for the day that did some volume now
we're going to spend about 15-20 minutes
just doing some accessories to to
continue sort of keeping that back
healthy and continue jacking that back
or that deadlift up i haven't ever seen
one of these seal row machines so i want
to hop on this probably do three or four
straight cuts on this to damn near
failure and then i'm thinking we're
going to do some pull-ups and some
reverse hyper combo but
subject to change of course
[Music]
[Music]
we got one final task gonna take a
picture
with the rep works t-shirts on to prove
to all the haters we were here and so
was refworks oh yeah let's get it okay
so just finished up our workout we did
some deadlifts we did some back what'd
you think dude i loved it uh people
brought their a game today obviously
brenda's not 100 healthy you're not a
hundred percent but you hit a heavy
single for the day and then we murdered
some volume and accessories so yeah what
would you take away from eating bread at
japan dude very very down to earth guys
it was really cool knowing that uh i
mean they got big audiences and they
were very uh very welcoming to bring me
in and let me show them show them a
little bit of how i do things yeah yeah
and i want to know like what what can
you expect when you go to the refworks
page or get a program from refworks so
the expectation that i that i like to
set and put out there is that it truly
is the the basic things that work right
there's all this i don't want to call it
misinformation but all this overly
elaborate sort of bs out there and i
talk about a lot i'm just sort of
looking to sort of pull the rug out from
under that and show that the simple
things do still work the best yeah so i
mean secondarily you can get in out of
the gym in a half hour and get an
awesome workout if you're willing to
just willing to really just kill it so
and a final question would be
if you're talking to somebody and you're
watching and you're struggling with
motivation or finding consistency and
finding a reason to get into the gym
every day what are some techniques that
you use as a guy with a full-time job
it's very busy to make sure that you
stay consistent in the gym i always just
understand that motivation is going to
come and go right and it's truly the
consistency over a long period of time
that matters so the days where you're
feeling good and you're excited to get
in the gym get in there and kill it but
the days where you're not quite feeling
100
get in there and do something check the
box for the day i like your no little
analogy you throw a nickel in the piggy
bank yeah because not every day is going
to be your best so don't bank on every
day feeling motivated but get in there
and just get your [ __ ] done oh yeah all
right well thanks for tuning in guys
this is nash from web rep works check
him out on ig
hit him up for a program if you guys
want a specific deadlift squat bench
program he knows what he's talking about
thanks for watching hopefully you got
some motivation for the day and you're
about to hit the gym right now hold that
out haters